people always ask us what advertising is
it's a business of rejection you have to
expect it
every day every day
i think advertising is like vandalism
it's
loud in your face and it's still there
the next day
if someone says this is going to be
really funny don't do that
don't tell people how to feel let them
feel through what you have
brands are allowed to have a social
conscience
with doritos we did rainbow chips for a
gay pride
parade and i think that's what's changed
in advertising you're allowed
to bring the social commentary into the
brand
that's a big deal and we're going to
talk about a 30-second
film
hello for 10 000 dollars
any commercial starts with finding the
truth
within the problem we weren't motivated
to drink more
milk by knowing that it was good for us
your mom told you that
i'm afraid your time is almost up that
was the whole campaign was
making people afraid to run out of milk
[Music]
got milk a lot of people think that
advertising is telling somebody
something that isn't true but getting
them to believe it
that's not what we do we understand it's
art serving capitalism
but we want to be artists in a business
world advertising is so fluid there is
no
consistency that this is what you should
be doing the key
is to be fearless you're not going to be
right all the time
just put your heart into something you
feel good about
you have to have a little fire burning
inside yourself and you have to be open
to the world
come and challenge us we want it bring
it
i'm goodby and i'm silverstein and this
is our master class
[Music]
so
[Music]
you